der einsatz begann exakt um vier uhr
morgens rund 800 beamte der
bundespolizei führten in fünf
bundesländern durchsuchungen durch der
grund ist der verdacht der illegalen
einschleusung von arbeitskräften für die
fleischindustrie mehr als 40 wohn und
geschäftsräume wurden dabei in berlin
nrw niedersachsen sachsen und sachsen
anhalt wie hier in weißenfels durchsucht
wir sind aktuell in 20 objekten in der
durchsuchung haben hier mehrere personen
festgestellt
das sind ungefähr 20 personen die wir
insgesamt hier im bereich weißenfels
festgestellt die unter anderem als
schein studenten ihre arbeit abgenommen
haben das heißt die personen haben von
vermittlern bescheinigung bekommen die
gefälscht sind nur vorgespiegelt wird
dass sie als studentin in universitäten
eingeschrieben sind
damit haben sie ja die möglichkeit legal
in
der eu zu arbeiten und genau das ist
hier im prinzip nicht nur eine illegale
einreise sondern auch illegale arbeit
die ermittlungen richten sich laut
bundespolizei gegen zehn
hauptbeschuldigte im alter von 41 bis 56
jahren
darunter sind acht männer und zwei
frauen es gehe um den vorwurf der
banden- und gewerbsmäßigen einschleusung
und der urkundenfälschung
die ermittler haben nach den angaben
werte in höhe von 1,5 millionen euro
beschlagnahmt
den illegal eingereisten leiharbeiter
droht nun die ausweisung aus deutschland
nach gehäuften krone infektion in
fleisch betrieben waren die
arbeitsbedingungen in der branche und
die unterbringung ausländischer
beschäftigter erneut in den fokus
gerückt das hatte eine bundesweite
debatte über die arbeitsbedingungen in
der branche ausgelöst
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren